لقد واجهنا تباطؤًا ثابتًا في الطلب
لجميع الأسباب الخارجة عن سيطرتنا ،
لقد قمنا بتعديل قدرتنا كما تقول
إنه نمو بنسبة 2٪ فقط ، لكن هل
هذا يعني أن نقول إن طيران الإمارات
ستكون عالقة عند 2٪ ، لا أفعل  نعتقد
أننا نعتقد أنها ستنتعش مرة أخرى
وستواصل طيران الإمارات تنمية
أعمالها ونعتقد أن هذه
الطائرة ستوظف بشكل مربح للغاية
في العديد من الوجهات الجديدة
بالإضافة إلى الوجهات الحالية ، لذا فهي
تمنحنا المزيد في ترسانتها  للتعامل
مع نوع تجزئة الطلب
الذي نتطلع إليه في العقد القادم
، أسميها فوضى مستمرة حيث
يحظر الحظر الاقتصادي المفروض على الكمبيوتر المحمول في قطر
الأنشطة الإرهابية في أوروبا كل
الأشياء التي تؤثر على نمو حركة المرور
هنا وما زلت تضغط على ذلك بشكل أفضل
من  450 مليون دولار في النصف الأول الخاص بك ،
اعتدنا نوعًا ما على
الصدمة مهما كان ذلك
الإرهابي الاقتصادي الجيوسياسي ، أطلق عليه ما
هو عليه حتى نتحسن فيه ، هذا
ما نفعله ونحصل عليه  لتكون قادرًا على
تولي الأعمال لتنمية الأعمال
التجارية وبعض الأشياء التي رأيتها اليوم
مع منتج 777 الجديد من الدرجة الأولى ، فإن
المجموعة التي قمنا بإعلانها
عن 787 ترسل رسالة واضحة
مفادها أننا  هنا لتنمية
أعمالنا ونحن في مجال الأعمال التجارية للبقاء لفترة
طويلة بشكل مربح لديك
نمو من رقم واحد في العام الماضي
والأمر نفسه بالنسبة للاتحاد والخطوط الجوية القطرية
يستنبط البعض ويقولون أن هذا
هو أفضل ما في الخليج  شركات النقل
في الماضي ولا يمكنهم العودة إلى الوراء
لقد مرت طيران الإمارات بفترات في تاريخها
حيث أكدنا على نمونا ، لقد استغلنا
السعة التي اتخذناها ،
وقد نسي
الناس التسعينيات من القرن الماضي ، وقد نسي الأشخاص 201 911
شخصًا 203  انتظر حتى
ننتظر خلال السنوات القليلة المقبلة ، انتظر حتى يتم بناء
دبي وورلد سنترال حيث نحن اليوم
بمائة وخمسين مليون
مسافر سنويًا.المطار ينمو إلى
220 مليون مسافر سنويًا ونرى
كيف ستبدو طيران الإمارات و
ربما لن أكون هنا ، لكن كيف
سيبدو الأمر بعد ذلك يمكنني أن أؤكد لكم أن
هؤلاء الأشخاص المهتمين
بما حدث في العام الماضي
سوف ينظرون إلى الوراء ويقولون نعم ربما لا يكون
هذا التعليق الجيد
لجعل الجميع هادئًا
صُدمت وقلت إن التعاون المحتمل
بين طيران الإمارات والاتحاد ،
كيف يتطور ذلك بمرور الوقت
ليكون أكثر قدرة على المنافسة ليس مثل
دبي وأبو ظبي
ولكن الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، وإذا كان بيانًا صادمًا
من السير تيم كلارك ، فأنا أتلقى
إرشادات من رؤسائي بشكل أساسي  إذا
أرادوا القيام بذلك ، فيمكننا القيام بالكثير
من الأشياء إذا أرادوا الذهاب
بعيدًا وهذا كل شيء لا أعرفه ولكن هناك
أشياء يمكننا القيام بها على الفور
معهم دون التعارض مع
قواعد المنافسة في الأسواق الخارجية
و  الحصول على قيمة أفضل
لكليهما ، أعتقد أن هذا ممكن ، وأعتقد أن رأيي
الشخصي في الأمر هو على الأرجح
ما تريده الملكية ، لكن هذه الأيام الأولى